you know but i think for me it's just
just kind of hitting people with like
music like you know what i'm saying yeah
you can't let people unfortunately man
unless you unless you're kendrick or
you're like the weekend or
you can't really like just sit on your
hands for three years yeah nah man look
roddy rich couldn't even do it yeah
exactly yeah that's my dog but like he i
feel like he waited too long
yeah you know what i mean like did you
like that project
his new album yeah i wasn't fond of it
where i didn't think it was as bad as
everyone said it was but i also didn't
think it was good and i'm a big fan of
him and and his whole discography and
uh
i just think sometimes when you sit on
[ __ ] too long you start psyching
yourself out about it
because i had heard stuff on that was
supposed to be on a version of his
second album
that wasn't on the album
and at least from what i've heard most
of his album that we
got was
fairly recently recorded
so i think artists make a mistake a lot
of times and i don't know i'm not
speaking on him in particular but i just
i do i do know that like
whenever you're sitting on a song for
too long it becomes old to you even if
no one's heard it that's true and then
you'll start to think that like the new
[ __ ] you did is better than the [ __ ]
that you knew you know was hard and it's
like it's just like
especially now man i think people
overthink their music they're like like
yo just like what you like just put some
[ __ ] out like put it out just put it out
let's put it out the longer you said it
just kind of like yeah and then like
people most music
that like like when i'm like like a lot
of artists that i know
i hear songs and i'm i'll talk to them
three or four years like you know
whatever happened to that [ __ ] song
right like
yeah yeah yeah and i'm not a fan of like
announcing like oh yeah new music coming
soon and then having people wait like
two
years or like you know for me if i'm
like yo new music's coming soon it's
probably coming in the future like
roddy's got to drop asap now like he's
really gotta like
yeah 90 days in the next 90 days we
better get some vermont yeah
i like him i like i really like him in
uh mustards um oh yeah they don't miss
yeah they are falling late at night high
fashion come on yeah yeah what i
actually heard was a lot of the um
original project was supposed to be more
like late at night a word so i don't
know what happened word i think i think
when you're someone like ronnie rich
you're like a pop star you're like a
superstar yeah yeah and i think that
like this project it felt to me like he
was trying to compete with like the
little babies and dirks of the world as
opposed to like the post malones of the
world if that makes sense right all
right i mean i'm like right you're a
stadium artist bro like right
right and it's all you know so it's all
a learning experience even for him for
sure you know for sure and he's a great
dude and he's and he's
so talented he's gonna be fine yeah but
i can only imagine like
mentally that's just got to take a toll
on you people talking [ __ ] about your
art so much yeah for sure i mean i was
just talking to somebody the other day
it's just kind of like you know as an
artist you know there's a level of
bravery that goes into being an artist
because you work on something so hard
that you think every every song that you
are preparing to put out you feel like
okay it's on the album for a reason you
must really [ __ ] with it right and then
you know you put it out in hopes that
people like it you know you put your
work out you know
just open to everybody everyone's
critiquing everyone is a critic now yeah
yeah and everybody's a twitter and or
yeah everyone has access to tell you how
they feel about your [ __ ] come on back
in the day they have to see with the
mall or something yeah exactly exactly
exactly they would have to you know
write fan mail or something like that
you know so
yeah no i definitely um
yeah i think he i think he'll be good